- I won again, Dad,
uh, I mean Coach.
- So you gentlemen have found my latest cheat,
the human centipede.
You see, Tom is getting old and needs extra protection.
- I'll then apply anti-aging organic eyeblack
made from the ashes of Jimmy Garoppolo's contract extension.
Gisele was wrong.
One day I will throw AND catch the ball.
- Light reps for the normal players,
meditation for Tom's cult.
- OK thanks, here's my special mind power.
- [Together:] Tooom.
- The Patriots do not rebuild,
we reload.
- Um, Coach are we cool?
- No.
Oh hi, Coach, have you met our terrible backup yet?
- Hello, I'm Thomas—
Whoops.
- Ha ha ha.
Thank goodness for the tuck rule.
Thanos didn't go far enough.
- I collected all six Coach. We can finally retire.
- Now you got to fill this one up.
- We deserve this.
- Think bigger.
- He's wrong, I don't need Coach.
- You'll always be pick 199.
- [Together:] ONE IS NOTHING WITHOUT THE OTHER.
- I AM MY OWN MAN!
- They grow up so fast.
- Where should I put my congrats card?
- Eli, No!
- Wahhh!
- I lied to Hulu. I'll do it, I'll move.
- I don't think about you as much as you think I do.
- Boy the Jets were tough. I don't know how we did it but—
- YO, if you enter a selfie, does it become a us-ie?
- Delete video.
- I'm football's Tom Brady.
Please buy my special pliability roombas.
- Uh, Tom, this is that subscribe thing for Bleacher Report.
- Why would I do that? Can't you get—
- Hi, I'm Julian Edelman and I know Tom Brady.
Please subscribe to this channel.